the president mentions it at every
campaign stop you just saw him there and
has made it one of the major issues this
election season the Central American
migrant caravans heading toward the u.s.
southern border tonight chief
intelligence correspondent Catherine
Herridge talks exclusively with Homeland
Security Secretary Kirsten Nielsen about
what the government truly knows about
who's traveling in those caravans and
how they are being organized financed
and managed we absolutely see people
from the Middle East from Southeast Asia
from other parts of the world these are
not just from Central America with
hundreds of migrants now arriving in
Mexico City 700 miles from the US border
the Homeland Security Secretary told Fox
News there is intelligence the caravans
include a limited number of individuals
from outside the region we don't always
know exactly who they are but it can
tell you is we stopped 3,000 people last
year at the southwest border who had
patterns of travel similar to a
terrorist I call the special interest
aliens Nielson said DHS is hearing real
concern from regional partners with
respect to the tiny and the particular
organization of these caravans they're
not organic if you will they're
definitely organized or financed Nielsen
also echoed warnings that the most
vulnerable are pushed ahead to frustrate
border police and the military they
don't want to get into a confrontation
with a child or women and so they're
almost being used as barriers and the
front of some of these caravans but what
I will say is the other caravans coming
up are mostly single males what I saw
was a high level of logistical
organization Latin America specialist
Joseph Hugh Mayer who was on the ground
with Guatemalan intelligence ten days
ago said some caravans operate in a
military fashion we already saw the
advance party of the second Caravan that
arrived about 48 hours before the main
body and they were there they were just
waiting at the border and they were
working through what's up groups and
they were communicating as to how much
security was at the border Democrats and
some Republicans accused the Trump
administration of fear-mongering over
the caravans former President Barack
Obama told the recent Miami rally the
deploying troops to the border is quote
a political stunt the Defense Secretary
has said they don't do stunts Brett
catherine herridge in washington
catherine thank you